Let's quickly review the difference between the
Control plane and the Data plane. The
control plane is the logic that controls
forwarding behavior. Examples of control plane functions include
routing protocols as well as logic for
configuring network middle boxes. Now, a routing protocol
might compute shortest paths or a topology.
But ultimately, the results of such computations must
be installed in switches that actually do
the forwarding. The forwarding table themselves and
specifically the actions associated with forwarding traffic
according to the Control plane logic is
what constitutes the data plane. So examples
of data plane function include forwarding packets
at the IP layer, and doing things like switching at layer two. So to reiterate,
routing protocol functions that compute the paths
are control plane functions. Where as, the act
of actually taking a packet, on an input
port, and forwarding it, to an output port,
is a data plane function. So why is separating the data and control planes a
good idea? The first reason, is independent evolution
and development. Thus, software control of the network,
can involve independently of the network hardware.
The second reason that separating data and control
plan is a good idea is the opportunity to control the network behavior from a
high-level software program. Controlling the network from
a high-level program in theory allows network operators
to debug and check network behavior more easily.
Then in the status quo, where network behavior
is determined by the distributed low level
configuration across hundreds of switches and routers.
The separation of data and control provides
opportunities for better network management and data
centers by facilitating such network tasks as
virtual machine migration to adapt to fluctuating
network demands. In Routing, the separation of
data and control provides more control over
decision logic. In Enterprise networks, SDN provides the ability to write
security applications such as applications
that manage network access control. In
Research networks, the separation of data and control. Effectively allows to
virtualize the network, so that, research
networks and experimental protocols can co-exist
with production networks on the same, underlying network hardware.